now the next game is one I'm pretty
excited about I like your good sing song
every now and again I like to I've never
get at dancing but I do have on stage
with me Jonathan from harmonics
how you doing Jonathan I'm doing great
what are you here to show off so I'm
here to show off Disney's Fantasia music
evolved it's a new Kinect project from
Disney and Harmonix Disney basically
came to us and said what would you do if
you were gonna reimagine Walt Disney's
Fantasia as an interactive experience
for the 21st century and at first we
were like I do I know that's
intimidating and then we spent a long
time we went to the Disney Archives we
sort of saw the inspirations behind the
whole project goop and we created this
this whole interactive music connect
experience that we're showing to you
right now really in fact we're looking
right now is one of the first time so
you guys are showing off the multi
players all right that's correct yeah
since e3 last year
we spent a long time sort of like
refining the story and how we welcome
players into the game and we also spent
a while adding this multiplayer mode
that we're looking at right now so we
see both players and Ed and Nick and
Vermont from our monix are playing right
now and you see them they're taking
turns and that's hitting the gold fuse
Nick's hitting the blue queues they're
working together hit the split ones you
see right now we're jumped in at this
moment where they're opening this
composition spell which basically lets
them out of musical solos in the middle
of a song so they're right in the middle
of divorce activity number nine and New
World Symphony and they're recording
their very own solo they can so this is
something we call the tone twister don't
let them spread their hands together and
apart they can pitch the music up and
down their trading sections back and
forth as they go so it's kind of like
this weird
jazzy live musical performance and then
as you play you get these moments like
you just saw we're actually blending
remixes together yes you might like the
choice there if you could go ahead like
on your one group where after the bass
the bass and I'm wondering with
something else
yeah the normal play is like the cues
that you're saying you trade these paths
you sweep in time with these cues and
then when you see those choice moments
you see those switch cues they let you
choose between three different remixes
for each song there's the original
version so for the classical stuff like
this piece we recorded a new version of
Dvorak symphony with the London Symphony
Orchestra on Abbey Road when we also do
two different remixes and just
completely different styles for every
song so for this one the pink remix that
Annette just selected it's actually a
chiptune remix it's like an 8-bit style
mix so you basically have something that
sounds like an old Nintendo or Amiga or
something on stage with LSO and then on
the green mix which Nick just selected
it's actually this jazzy big band mix so
it starts out in the sift phonics base
and just get super crazy everything fits
together but it's just completely so
right now we've got like some chip gene
and some jazz tool smooshed together
yeah do we want the player to just
imagine how we like show those
instruments till I felt them a bad - how
weird it would be to just imagine the
orchestra jamming away no weakness so we
started this demo kind of like already
into the into the game but explain a
little bit about how it works in
generally when the player picks up turns
it on the dog immediately thrust into a
right of emotion dancing scenario are
they we sort of we walk people in very
gently since last year we came here
we've shown up the basic game but there
was a lot for people to grasp but it's a
really unusual project really ambitious
project yeah and so we spent a long time
looking at what is it gonna take to
welcome people into this experience how
can we connect with the thing that
people remember
from Walt Disney's Fantasia so he sort
of like took the jumping off point and
the original Sorcerer's Apprentice
Shores like obviously the proof is that
we have to enjoy with her very much
inspired by that sort of like conducting
the heavens in the oceans but we
actually welcome you in as the new
Sorcerer's Apprentice you personally
will meet the master sorcerer yen sid's
you'll become the new apprentice and
he'll basically teach you the basics
we've got a sweep of t2 out of first
Lake to feel like you are conducting and
controlling this music and then you're
gonna be this new character the smaller
Francis named Scout very ambitious prone
to getting into trouble as apprentices
tend to do and the two of you will
discover the remix magic that allows you
to transform the songs as you do in the
game you only sness force called the
noise which is threatening to sort of
unmake the music of Fantasia together
the two of you are gonna have to explore
the realms of Fantasia
they simply wander through them and
perform the songs to bring out new music
record your own music to really to
basically create a nude so on the idea
of music like Aaron earth did you decide
what music to include or whatsoever last
year you should have Queen yeah I'm a
huge Queen fan so you had me sold there
but like how on earth yeah how did you
go about choosing the chains because you
could basically pick from anywhere as
seems right so what did you choose and
how did you go about it so it was a very
like broadband name our goal was
basically to say like you know when
Disney created the original film in 1940
his goal was for it to kind of be this
living concert feature that would grow
and evolve over time and so we basically
imagine what would have happened if that
had gone on so we brought in you know in
the 70s we would have like imagine that
Queen would come in we have a modern
stuff we have like CeeLo
we have some like really like surprising
like the DES latest stuff like Lorde
Royals is in the game but then we're
also true to the classic affair like his
goal was really to like allow people to
connect with music and different
so that's sort of like drove our choices
like what's gonna be fun to play what's
going to be interesting to sort of like
interpret each song like inspires one of
the realms of the Fantasia that the
players will visit and we combine
multiple songs into each realm to create
a little concert for the player so like
tell me some of your favorite songs you
including the game like well the ones
that people are home gonna really
recognize so ones that like the Disney
fans working at one of my favorite
rounds is this one that we've shown off
called the hollow which is like it's
called the hollow oh yeah it's this
mystical forest it's kind of inspired by
like old world like Brothers Grimm dark
fantasy okay and it's our home for we
took night on ball bouncing from the
original film and we sort of
reinterpreted it so we have the
classical symphonic recording and we
also allow players to do like weird like
electronic modifications and like
snarling guitars adding them into the
mix and then on the other side a realm
is the White Stripes seven nation army
okay so you've got like these two
intense bombastic songs you know very
different style from symphonic to garage
rock but then as you blend them together
like you start finding the commonality
and their spirit kind of like infuses
the world with magic with like
transformations you know there's these
fairies like bust out of a well after
you play The White Stripes and a Baba
Yaga chicken hut dances to the is never
something I thought I'd seen so that's
good um so I've got a question for the
chat and it simply says connect
questions so I'll be playing this on
connect right now we are playing this
it's on Kinect for Xbox one and Xbox 360
I mean look if you know Harmonix like
obviously we're big fans of Kinect we've
been doing Dance Central for a while we
got Dance Central spotlight coming out
this fall when Disney came to us with
this project it was basically like I
said with that mandate to sort of like
take that goal of how people are how
people are inspired by music and can
connect with music and we really felt
that like Kinect was an ideal platform
for this like if you want to feel like
your Mickey Mouse controlling the music
like we can build that as a controller
game but it's not gonna have the same
physicality like you know when we're
watching an ethnic play right now people
really get into it it's a lot sort of
like lower impact than Dance Central
front because it's really just about
moving your hands on the timing of
moving your hands but it gets really
intense as you get to the harder songs
and then as you're playing together like
it's fun to see people who have played
for a while like working in their own
kind of like choreography and special
moments into it so Deb we're still like
we're still big believers it's sort of
the magic that you could do with connect
and we hope that this this game well
show prove that to a lot of people going
it must be interesting for you guys
obviously was like Microsoft slight
change of you guys that your industry is
it's like built on thank you Bush's
sensors it's not a game that you could
choose to have without it right so it's
turn I mean we could we considered it
you know we really looked at what would
be the best experience for this game you
know not only with our own studio
expertise coming off of Dance Central
and sort of how to fit the platform well
but but yeah like I said to be true to
that vision like it felt like the right
thing because we've had we've had just
kids come up and play we defies like
older folks who are fans of the original
come up and play and there's just a
learning curve to it like it's not just
like not just like a waggle based like
and whatever you want to get enough to
learn the timing and you have to sort of
go through your apprenticeship with the
sorcerer but once you get the hang of it
really like kids are doing stuff that
there's you know then they never even
expected if you tell a kid like oh
you're gonna conduct music they don't
even know what that means but then they
play for an hour they're like oh I get
it it's that thing where I'm controlling
the music with the stick to like got it
so I'm we're looking for a player of a
scene at the moment that the single
player is that the narrative driven
aspect for a game is your narrative
aspect to the multiplayer or is it more
like individual songs at your pace the
multi player score so what happens is
that like you'll play the song line or
you'll play the adventure so to go
through the story become the approach
learn how to remix song so basically in
forward more control to open up
composition spells of mobility to
transform the songs as you go and then
that opens up a song library which is
basically like any of our dense central
fans be very familiar to them like it's
a similar sort of like the already play
experience jump in and play the songs
with their friends extend your song
library with downloadable content we
even let you do like one of the fun
things is because the games about
blending remixes will let you download
additional remixes so if you just want
to drop out the original and just play
with straight remixes of the song to
blend them together you and your friends
can do that that sounds like a lot of
fun well thank you so much for coming on
stage again and for second year running
and showing us TV my name's give you
second Bowl so Cheers pleasure tiny
moonlets and guys thanks for staying
with us